Caption: thank you very much hello everybody
Caption: my name is Mandy just a quick thing
Caption: there are some amazing illustrations in
Caption: my presentation now I didn't make those
Caption: I'm a developer that by burnt toys
Caption: creative I have a slide at the end they
Caption: are on Twitter they're awesome but
Caption: you'll see them as you go through and
Caption: you'll appreciate them as much as I did
Caption: so why are we talking about HTML because
Caption: there are a lot of amazing things to
Caption: talk about as we've discovered today
Caption: with all the awesome streams and talks
Caption: and things but for me I think the read
Caption: it I get asked why I made this
Caption: presentation because a lot of people
Caption: think that HTML is really simple and you
Caption: know it I would say it probably is a
Caption: simple language to learn and work with
Caption: we can get something going very quickly
Caption: we can accomplish things quite quite
Caption: quickly and it's very forgiving if we
Caption: make mistakes but I think sometimes that
Caption: we make the mistake that assuming
Caption: because it's simple it's not valuable
Caption: and with you know all the amazing things
Caption: with JavaScript and CSS and all the
Caption: other programming languages and
Caption: technologies that are out there we
Caption: forget that hTML is an important part of
Caption: what we do on the web
Caption: so I want to tell you a little bit of a
Caption: story about how I wrote this
Caption: presentation just for some context and
Caption: why I came to write it and it was
Caption: because last year around this time I was
Caption: in Melbourne speaking at code and I was
Caption: talking about CSS and I happen to be on
Caption: a CSS panel and a question came up and
Caption: the question was does anybody hire
Caption: people who only write CSS and HTML and
Caption: the answer was no people don't do that
Caption: anymore because JavaScript is really
Caption: important and it's the most valuable
Caption: programming language for the web I was a
Caption: bit disappointed by this because I still
Caption: think that there's a lot of value in
Caption: HTML and CSS
Caption: and I think this value in people
Caption: learning it but because of that I wrote
Caption: an article you may or may not have read
Caption: it it was cold is there any value in
Caption: people who cannot write JavaScript the
Caption: titles a little bit emotive and for
Caption: everyone who bothered to read it before
Caption: commenting yeah there were a lot of
Caption: comments and a lot of people didn't read
Caption: the article before they they responded
Caption: it basically the TI was that yes I do
Caption: think there's value in people who don't
Caption: write JavaScript I think there's value
Caption: on people who only write JavaScript who
Caption: only write HTML and CSS who do all of it
Caption: who do all sorts of things but I do
Caption: think that people who write HTML and
Caption: have a deep understanding of it or at
Caption: least use it to its full potential is
Caption: becoming very rare at least it feels
Caption: that way to me and when I wrote this
Caption: articles there were a lot of opinions
Caption: about it
Caption: a lot of them weren't very nice I don't
Caption: read the comments anymore but a lot of
Caption: other people had opinions about this and
Caption: they wrote blog posts and they had
Caption: discussions about it and podcasts and
Caption: tweets and all sorts of things I was all
Caption: around the purpose and the role that
Caption: HTML and CSS in this case play in a
Caption: world where JavaScript is king and is
Caption: what everybody cares about and what
Caption: everyone is hiring for but for me it's
Caption: really really simple hTML is a part of
Caption: the web it always has been and we need
Caption: to consider a variety of people tools
Caption: and technology that consume our webpages
Caption: and it's not just about the tech that we
Caption: have now like the browser's or assistive
Caption: technology search engines or even at
Caption: that consumer size it's about whatever
Caption: comes next in the future we have
Caption: technology now like the Google home and
Caption: Alexa what happens when they try to read
Caption: our websites are they going to interpret
Caption: it and consume it the way that we
Caption: expected it to so what I want to talk
Caption: about today
Caption: I don't want to teach you H tml what I
Caption: want to talk about is how different
Caption: technologies consume our websites and
Caption: consume our HTML and how we can do some
Caption: things to try and make sure that it has
Caption: its best opportunity and best chance to
Caption: be interpreted and consumed and
Caption: represented the way that we want it to
Caption: regardless of where it is so that brings
Caption: me to my talk which is function or HTML
Caption: now I must admit I mean obviously my
Caption: article was probably poorly titled I
Caption: didn't really think about the whole
Caption: functional programming thing when I
Caption: named this it that's not why I called it
Caption: that I'm not talking about functional
Caption: programming and HTML so if you came here
Caption: thinking that I apologize
Caption: you should still stay because it's gonna
Caption: be great but the reason I called it
Caption: funky ml is because I've heard this
Caption: quote or phrase from developers that
Caption: I've worked in for years and that's I'm
Caption: just making it functional right now and
Caption: what that typically translates to is I'm
Caption: just writing the JavaScript you know the
Caption: functional parts I'll make it pretty
Caption: later and the problem with this is that
Caption: when we what we're doing is we're
Caption: relegating HTML and CSS to just making
Caption: things pretty and that couldn't be
Caption: further from the truth because for
Caption: something to be functional it should be
Caption: practical and useful it needs to be
Caption: working properly and as we expect it to
Caption: and not just for someone looking at it
Caption: in a browser but for any technology that
Caption: tries to look at our websites however
Caption: given that the browser is the most
Caption: common way that people consume our
Caption: websites I want to talk quickly and very
Caption: very simply about how the browser
Caption: interprets our HTML now I'm gonna
Caption: preface this with obviously it's way
Caption: more complicated than the three icons
Caption: I'm going to show you but I just wanted
Caption: to touch on it quickly so first we type
Caption: our code like that cat in the gift
Caption: and we give the browser our suite HTML
Caption: file and we're like cool
Caption: there you go browser take my HTML and
Caption: then it takes that and it looks at it
Caption: but it doesn't just take our HTML and
Caption: make the page like it actually has to
Caption: construct the page from that and what it
Caption: does is it gets this big long string and
Caption: it goes through and it starts to create
Caption: all of the parent and child
Caption: relationships that we've presented in
Caption: our HTML and this it just goes through
Caption: everything until it gets to the end and
Caption: that's how we get the Dom tree or the
Caption: document object model and that's what
Caption: you see typically when you inspect your
Caption: code in the browser like in Chrome or
Caption: Firefox or whatever and that's how we
Caption: manipulate edit and move things around
Caption: in our documents now in order for it to
Caption: actually display there are a couple more
Caption: steps the paint and composite processes
Caption: which I won't go into but why does it
Caption: matter what our browser and how it
Caption: interprets our HTML and I think it
Caption: matters because what the browser does
Caption: constructs is based on what we give it
Caption: so if we request a dim it gives us a div
Caption: if we give it something that it doesn't
Caption: understand or like dogs are amazing
Caption: element it's still gonna put that in the
Caption: page and it's still going to render your
Caption: content it doesn't care what the HTML
Caption: elements are it's just going to
Caption: construct the parent and child
Caption: relationships it gives us what we've
Caption: asked for so on that note we're just
Caption: gonna take a brief sidestep and talk
Caption: about typescript has anyone here use
Caption: typescript or flow or anything ok cool a
Caption: few people so for those that don't know
Caption: typescript is a typed JavaScript
Caption: language it does everything that
Caption: JavaScript does plus other things and
Caption: basically it makes use of static typing
Caption: so you can give your variable a type
Caption: when you write your code and then what
Caption: it does at compile time is it going when
Caption: it checks that the type of content or
Caption: data that you're passing through to your
Caption: variables matches what you asked for
Caption: and if it doesn't it throws an error so
Caption: this is some type script it's an
Caption: interface for a dog got a name which is
Caption: a string an age which is a number and a
Caption: is fluffy which is a boolean so true or
Caption: false because not all dogs are fluffy
Caption: they're all amazing but they're not all
Caption: fluffy and in this case we're assigning
Caption: the type to our data and whether or not
Caption: we want to get what we want to get from
Caption: that content and if I pass a number to
Caption: my name it'll throw an error it will say
Caption: no no you said you wanted a string
Caption: you've given me a number and you can go
Caption: and do something about that and what
Caption: we're doing is we're telling types with
Caption: what we expect our data to be and this
Caption: makes debugging reading writing and
Caption: working with our code a lot easier at
Caption: least in my opinion we're being really
Caption: explicit about what the shape of our
Caption: data should be and this is pretty much
Caption: what we do in HTML we specify whether we
Caption: want a heading what kind of heading it
Caption: should be if we need a list navigation
Caption: items links buttons bold italic images
Caption: captions we're choosing an element that
Caption: both best represents our content and
Caption: there are a whole range of elements that
Caption: we can use in order to markup our
Caption: content correctly and we do this for the
Caption: same reason we do it in tight script to
Caption: define the shape of our content to make
Caption: it easier to work read and write and not
Caption: just for us but for whatever tech tries
Caption: to consumers and in typescript we have
Caption: this concept of in any time and in any
Caption: type means basically that my name can be
Caption: anything it can be a number a boolean a
Caption: string and this can be useful on
Caption: occasion but if you type everything as
Caption: any you start to lose the benefits of
Caption: the language because you're no longer
Caption: getting the type checking it's not going
Caption: to throw an error when you pass a number
Caption: to name the safety that typescript
Caption: provides is gone and it becomes
Caption: pointless
Caption: and this is the same in HTML if you use
Caption: dibs everywhere you're not making the
Caption: most of the language so because of this
Caption: it's really important that we actively
Caption: choose what the right element for our
Caption: content is and you don't just default to
Caption: using a div and if we look at a really
Caption: simple example of a page about why dogs
Caption: are good just using games this is what
Caption: it looks like in the browser
Caption: it's just default browser styling
Caption: everything is a div even the links which
Caption: I've added javascript on click event to
Caption: to make it clickable and you can see
Caption: that the page is a bit unstructured
Caption: there isn't really much meaning except
Caption: from the whitespace that we get from the
Caption: div being a block element whereas if we
Caption: look at a more semantic page which has
Caption: properly chosen HTML elements like lists
Caption: and links and images and big captions
Caption: headings you can see a structure starts
Caption: to form and there's value in this it's
Caption: already more practical and more useful
Caption: than this page because we we have a
Caption: hierarchy and you might be thinking well
Caption: okay sure but I could make this look
Caption: like this with CSS and you're right you
Caption: could but the problem with that is that
Caption: not everything that consumes your page
Caption: is going to have access to your CSS and
Caption: your JavaScript they're going to
Caption: evaluate your page based on the HTML
Caption: that you've provided it doesn't care
Caption: about all the other stuff that you've
Caption: done and it's easy to assume that the
Caption: way our HTML is going to be consumed is
Caption: gonna be the same way that we as
Caption: developers and the creators of the site
Caption: can see it in our browser but there are
Caption: so many different technologies that will
Caption: try to read use understand and consume
Caption: our HTML and they rely on us to use the
Caption: language properly in order for it to
Caption: make sense so the first one I wanted to
Caption: talk about is assistive tab now using
Caption: HTML as its intended helps us to build
Caption: web pages and
Caption: vacations that can be used by a wide
Caption: range of people in a wide range of
Caption: circumstances and there are a bunch of
Caption: different options in the assistive tech
Caption: space there's screen readers brow
Caption: readers switches even the Google home
Caption: and Alexa are being used by people as a
Caption: form of assistive technology I'm gonna
Caption: focus on the screen reader today mainly
Caption: because that's the one I know how to use
Caption: yes
Caption: but before I do my screen reader jenamae
Caption: I wanted to talk about the accessibility
Caption: tree because I think a lot of people
Caption: don't actually know that it exists I
Caption: much like the browser creates the Dom it
Caption: takes the don tree and it modifies it to
Caption: form something that's useful to
Caption: assistive technology and that's what the
Caption: accessibility tree is and it uses native
Caption: semantics to create an interface for
Caption: reading and navigating the page for
Caption: example a screen reader is able to
Caption: interpret the accessibility tree and
Caption: reproduce the text-to-speech and some
Caption: things are stripped out so anything that
Caption: is not useful for someone who can't see
Caption: the page that's removed but other things
Caption: are added in so around forms and
Caption: interactions for example additional
Caption: context is provided to make
Caption: understanding the page easier so if we
Caption: take that deep only example off dogs are
Caption: good earlier what does that sound like
Caption: to a spring we know what what does a div
Caption: only page how does it get interpreted by
Caption: assistive technologies like a screen
Caption: reader so to make it easier for you
Caption: because when I did this the first time
Caption: for my co-workers they couldn't follow
Caption: along and they were very confused
Caption: I have captions which are down the
Caption: bottom and then also it'll highlight
Caption: every line as we go through this is
Caption: using voiceover on the Mac fingers cross
Caption: our family dogs are good a job where
Caption: content you are currently on web content
Caption: dogs are good a job web content home
Caption: good dogs
Caption: bad dog myths dogs they are good we are
Caption: dedicated to educating the world
Caption: my dogs are good and how they can make
Caption: your life good by Mandy Michael comma
Caption: August 3 road to zero one eight why our
Caption: dogs good dogs are loyal intelligent
Caption: devoted and affectionate they are known
Caption: to improve our physical and mental
Caption: health Michiyo and jello also known as
Caption: jell-o / screen percent to zero shot % 2
Caption: 0 2 0 1 2 that sorry firstly the image
Caption: let's address that seeing it was the
Caption: last thing I did that by accident if I'm
Caption: being honest I screenshotted that
Caption: picture of my dog jello Michelangelo
Caption: just FYI the screen reader clearly had
Caption: trouble with that from Instagram and I
Caption: forgot to change the file name and
Caption: because I was making a not awesome HTML
Caption: page I didn't put an alt tag on it so it
Caption: had to read out a very long really
Caption: horrible filename so lesson number one
Caption: rename your files um or better add an
Caption: alt tag but you know when you when
Caption: you're reading through that page it it's
Caption: kind of just a big blob of text right
Caption: and it didn't even tell me that the top
Caption: three things were linked there was no
Caption: way for me to know that because the
Caption: screen reader doesn't know that those
Caption: divs with that on click event were
Caption: actually pages that that I could go to
Caption: and I could visit and that can be pretty
Caption: confusing because you've just kind of
Caption: got a guess based on the fact that there
Caption: are no other words after it but
Caption: typically people using assistive
Caption: technology will listen to this at a much
Caption: faster pace so they might not notice
Caption: that if there's no hierarchy or
Caption: structure there and often they would use
Caption: keyboard shortcuts or other ways to
Caption: navigate around the page so they don't
Caption: have to read it from top to bottom and
Caption: sometimes they do this with headings for
Caption: example so they can skip to different
Caption: headings on the page and go oh yeah I
Caption: want to I want to find out why they're
Caption: good or the related links or did you
Caption: know which is further down the page but
Caption: without those keys they're forced to
Caption: read everything or more likely they're
Caption: just gonna leave
Caption: is you know that's a pain especially
Caption: when they get to my really horrible file
Caption: name on my image which is a shame
Caption: because then they won't find out why
Caption: dogs are good so what about the
Caption: structured more semantic version of my
Caption: page what does that sound like in a
Caption: spring reader same again captions and
Caption: highlighting you are currently on web
Caption: content dogs are good I just read
Caption: content navigation main navigation one
Caption: item list three items visited link home
Caption: link good dogs link
Caption: bad dog miss heading level one dogs they
Caption: are good we are dedicated to educating
Caption: the world on why dogs are good and how
Caption: they can make your life good Mandy
Caption: Michael August 3rd 2018 heading level 2
Caption: why our dogs good dogs are loyal
Caption: intelligent devoted and affectionate
Caption: they are known to improve our physical
Caption: and mental health a dog named Nicky
Caption: Langella waso known as cello image group
Caption: international sorry you can already hear
Caption: in that example that it's a lot better
Caption: it tells me upfront that I've got
Caption: navigation items how many there are that
Caption: I visited a link what links ah it tells
Caption: me what a heading one is what a heading
Caption: two is it didn't read out a really long
Caption: faux name it's already providing us more
Caption: context and information to navigate the
Caption: page with and this isn't just valuable
Caption: for screen readers but potentially also
Caption: really useful for google home and Alexa
Caption: to be able to navigate around the page
Caption: based on voice commands so my point here
Caption: is don't just use dibs because you're
Caption: losing out all that free information
Caption: that you get by just picking the right
Caption: HTML element otherwise you're going to
Caption: have to put a lot more work in to try
Caption: and get that content to make sense to
Caption: someone else and I'm gonna quote
Caption: Jeffrey's old win because I read this
Caption: article recently and I loved it but to
Caption: build for people and the long term then
Caption: simple structural semantic hTML was best
Caption: each element deployed for its intended
Caption: purpose don't use a div when you mean a
Caption: P or a paragraph and there are a lot of
Caption: things that we can do to make a HTML
Caption: read
Caption: better for screen readers and other
Caption: technologies like search engines as well
Caption: and one of those things is using
Caption: sectioning elements and what sectioning
Caption: elements do is they create a document
Caption: outline and that's used by the
Caption: accessibility tree to form an outline of
Caption: what is on the page now prior to html5
Caption: we didn't have sectioning elements we
Caption: just had dibs
Caption: and that made automating a document
Caption: outline impossible because there's no
Caption: way to know the difference between a
Caption: section marked off as a div and just a
Caption: div that's used for presentational
Caption: purposes so now that we have sectioning
Caption: elements the browser can automate a
Caption: document outline that can be used by
Caption: search engines screen readers and other
Caption: apps and code that try to read our page
Caption: and that's incredibly valuable and
Caption: powerful and it's not that much work to
Caption: implement now there are four sectioning
Caption: elements the section unsurprising this
Caption: represents a standalone section that has
Caption: no other semantic meaning and because
Caption: it's used in the document outline you
Caption: should never use this if you want a
Caption: generic container if you want a generic
Caption: container use a div I know I said don't
Caption: just use dibs but
Caption: generic containers are what divs are for
Caption: the article is another one and this is
Caption: used for self-contained parts of the
Caption: page so if you think about content that
Caption: can be redistributed or reusable like in
Caption: syndication use the article element and
Caption: this is used a lot for blog news
Caption: articles forums that kind of thing now
Caption: there's another one which you heard in
Caption: the screenreader demo this provides
Caption: context around navigation items and it's
Caption: used for a table of contents may now
Caption: have that kind of stuff and then there's
Caption: the aside which is my favorite this is
Caption: used to markup content around but that's
Caption: not part of the main outline and I like
Caption: this because it's great in like news
Caption: articles for example when people are
Caption: trying to shove stuff in the middle of
Caption: that article that you're trying to read
Caption: if you mark that up as an aside it's
Caption: ignored in the main
Caption: outline of the page sidebars call-out
Caption: boxes that kind of thing and you can use
Caption: these in conjunction with a more clear
Caption: structure and hierarchy and this allows
Caption: search engines to better understand the
Caption: content that we're writing and what's
Caption: the most valuable content on the site
Caption: headings are one thing that a lot of
Caption: people don't use that well to be honest
Caption: the h1 is used to represent the main
Caption: purpose of the page page 2 to h6
Caption: all subheadings and a screen reader can
Caption: take a list of headings from your page
Caption: create that and allow users to get a
Caption: read through all of those and decide if
Caption: they want to actually read the page at
Caption: all it gives them an idea of what's on
Caption: the page and that's really really useful
Caption: so you should always use a heading
Caption: inside your sections a header element is
Caption: another one this isn't a sectioning
Caption: element but it is used to provide
Caption: context around the header of your page
Caption: like main navigation search logos that
Caption: kind of thing and there's a footer
Caption: element as well which does the same for
Caption: footer content and a main element that
Caption: does the same for the main part of your
Caption: page but we should also make the most of
Caption: built-in functionality because we've got
Caption: enough to do right we have to do linking
Caption: right tests right a shit-ton a
Caption: JavaScript you know I don't have time to
Caption: rebuild the web I've got other things to
Caption: do and a really good example of that is
Caption: the link or the anchor element this
Caption: comes with so much for free the people
Caption: are not taking advantage of it navigates
Caption: the user to a new page it changes the
Caption: URL it causes the browser to redraw and
Caption: refresh its focusable with the hey
Caption: stress element attribute it can register
Caption: a click with the Enter key it has
Caption: visited focus hover link and active
Caption: States and it allows opening in a window
Caption: all for free you don't have to do
Caption: anything that will just work when you
Caption: use the link
Caption: and yet for some reason we keep using
Caption: dims and trying to recreate that I don't
Caption: know about you but I would rather be
Caption: padding my dog than spending time making
Caption: something open in a new window with
Caption: JavaScript and the same goes for the
Caption: button element right this can be focused
Caption: by default you can click it with the
Caption: space key it can be disabled with the
Caption: disabled attribute it can submit and
Caption: reset a form you can stroke focus hover
Caption: active and disabled States by default I
Caption: don't spend your time remaking something
Caption: that already exists and if you don't
Caption: know when to use a button versus an
Caption: anchor or a link a good rule of thumb is
Caption: a link navigates to a new page a button
Caption: toggles something in your interface the
Caption: way that I like to think of it is if it
Caption: has a href it's a link if it doesn't or
Caption: you're disabling the hey trap it's
Caption: probably a button I mean obviously there
Caption: are exceptions to this but that's a good
Caption: place to start and probably the best
Caption: thing about HTML is that you can combine
Caption: them to create even better and more
Caption: improved context and a great example of
Caption: this is the figure in the figcaption
Caption: these are self-contained units of
Caption: content and it means that you can move
Caption: it around the page and it'll still make
Caption: sense
Caption: and inside the fit caption you can put
Caption: other elements like paragraphs and
Caption: headings to give even more information
Caption: in context and inside of the figure with
Caption: the figcaption you can put the pre
Caption: element and the pre element marks are
Caption: pre-formatted text and if you combine
Caption: that with the figure in the figcaption
Caption: then you get a more accessible pre
Caption: formatted text on your page and when
Caption: this is rendered with a mono spaced font
Caption: on its own the screen reader tries to
Caption: read out each character by itself which
Caption: is not great so the figure and
Caption: figcaption marks the coin up as a figure
Caption: and the feed caption as the description
Caption: and the abbreviation and definition
Caption: elements which are my favorite these are
Caption: so great I wish people use these more it
Caption: allows browsers and BOTS and
Caption: to recognize that a phrases being
Caption: defined and that that acronym is
Caption: associated to the phrase so for example
Caption: I actually put code up for this because
Caption: it's hard to explain but we have a
Caption: description about the International good
Caption: dogs association which determines that
Caption: all dogs are good and we have an
Caption: abbreviation of IG da and that's wrapped
Caption: in the abbreviation element and that has
Caption: a title of international good dogs
Caption: association and then inside that outside
Caption: of that we wrap it in the definition
Caption: element and that says that this
Caption: paragraph is defined defining IG da
Caption: which is an abbreviation of
Caption: international good dog's Association and
Caption: all the tech understands that because
Caption: it's part of HTML and there are heaps of
Caption: elements there's the progress bar
Caption: there's bi-directional which is the by
Caption: day one that makes text go right to left
Caption: instead of left to right
Caption: KBD might sup keyboard controls if you
Caption: need to display those there's video
Caption: which gives you video controls there's a
Caption: dialogue audio time and this is just a
Caption: tiny little bit and you don't have to
Caption: remember them all because the Mozilla
Caption: developer Network has a totally amazing
Caption: page that you can just search and it'll
Caption: give you back a list of them and it'll
Caption: tell you how you can use them and I kind
Caption: of think that like I said before with
Caption: all of the other things that we need to
Caption: do with our deployment processes and our
Caption: build chains and our naming things our
Caption: tests and using typescript like make
Caption: your life easier and see the heap of
Caption: time by just picking the right HTML
Caption: element because it makes your project
Caption: more understandable but it also makes
Caption: like to me as a developer but also to
Caption: people trying to use it and technology
Caption: trying to consume it but I could talk
Caption: about those all day and I don't want to
Caption: do that
Caption: so what I want to show you is the way
Caption: that some other tech consumes our HTML
Caption: and a really good example of this is
Caption: reading apps like instant paper and
Caption: pocket and what they do is they take
Caption: structured content and they
Caption: display it with custom styles and they
Caption: provide improved readability and options
Caption: for personalization and people can use
Caption: these for all sorts of reasons better
Caption: accessibility so improve contrast for
Caption: example or the aesthetics because what
Caption: these do is they strip out all of the
Caption: extra junk on a page like ads for
Caption: example so it's just a nicer experience
Caption: now I use instapaper so this is the one
Caption: I'm gonna start with and what this does
Caption: is it allows you to save articles and
Caption: you can read them later in their reading
Caption: mode and this is what the diversion
Caption: looks like in their reading mode now it
Caption: kind of looks like the same as before
Caption: right
Caption: but it's different color not very well
Caption: structured we already understand that
Caption: but what about the better more semantic
Caption: version it kind of looks like the other
Caption: page right they've managed to apply
Caption: their own styles to my links and my
Caption: lists and my headings but also at the
Caption: top you'll notice the links aren't there
Caption: anymore and that's because we don't need
Caption: the links in this context and because I
Caption: mark them up as a navigation item it can
Caption: remove those which is great it's also
Caption: put my name and the date at the top and
Caption: this information is really important in
Caption: Instapaper because I have like 400
Caption: articles that I'm meaning to get to if I
Caption: don't have who wrote it and when how am
Caption: I going to know if that's still relevant
Caption: to me or if I can trust the person that
Caption: wrote that article or if I think Mandy
Caption: Michael writes really sweet articles
Caption: with non-offensive titles I can go and
Caption: read those later it's really important
Caption: not just for the user but from a
Caption: publishers perspective because if I want
Caption: people to think my content is great and
Caption: I don't tell them that I wrote it how
Caption: will they know to come back and read
Caption: more of what I've written
Caption: now pocket is another example which does
Caption: the same thing as Instapaper but this
Caption: one's really interesting I didn't
Caption: actually use pocket so I had to play
Caption: around with this a bit to get it to work
Caption: and this is what it looks like in the
Caption: web view this is both of my my pages one
Caption: with divs why
Caption: with semantic HTML this first one
Caption: obviously the div version you'll notice
Caption: that the title is different that's
Caption: because there's no h1 on my page so
Caption: instead of putting the h1 in there use
Caption: the title element which is the only
Caption: title that could find there's no image
Caption: even though I did use an image element
Caption: in the page to load the image in it
Caption: couldn't find it sometimes it would load
Caption: random text from the page like from
Caption: anywhere it didn't really matter where
Caption: which was weird I also couldn't read it
Caption: in there reading up it I had to open it
Caption: in a new window from the original page
Caption: and it was really clear to me that
Caption: Pocket was having a bit of trouble
Caption: understanding what to do with my div
Caption: only page it even took longer to process
Caption: which is weird because the page isn't
Caption: very big and the most interesting thing
Caption: I came across was the desktop app so
Caption: while the mobile app I couldn't read it
Caption: in there a fat all the desktop one I
Caption: could but it flagged my content as being
Caption: not article content and that I thought
Caption: was a bit weird and from a like
Caption: publisher perspective or from a brand
Caption: perspective that's probably quite
Caption: damaging because when I saw that the
Caption: first thing I thought was oh he says
Caption: something like bad about that page and
Caption: then I was like no no I made this page
Caption: it's fine but it's like a box at the top
Caption: you know it's scary you wax now the more
Caption: semantic version already looks better
Caption: it's got a cute dog o on it it's got the
Caption: right title I can open it up in there
Caption: reading up it looks pretty good they've
Caption: put their own styles in great also at
Caption: the top it's got my name and the date
Caption: much like Instapaper did and this is
Caption: really really awesome when so the other
Caption: one I looked at was Safari reading mode
Caption: now this one's my favorite because in
Caption: Safari it's there by default you click
Caption: the little lines next to the URL bar if
Caption: it's not there there's something wrong
Caption: with your page
Caption: I'll be honest the dead version did not
Caption: work I could not use Safari reading mode
Caption: on it which was unfortunate but I could
Caption: use my more semantic content however I
Caption: didn't really work that well and kind of
Caption: mislead you a tiny bit pocket and
Caption: Instapaper originally didn't put my name
Caption: and byline at the top of the page and
Caption: safari reading mode was missing content
Caption: there was no bullets no quotes no links
Caption: further down and even paragraphs were
Caption: missing and I was very very confused I
Caption: do not know what's going on and I
Caption: panicked a little bit because the whole
Caption: point of my presentation was that HTML
Caption: and semantic hTML mattered and you know
Caption: this is how technology consumes your
Caption: sites and I was like my life is a lie I
Caption: don't know what to do HTML so a panicked
Caption: big time and I went on Twitter as I do
Caption: when I panic that's a mistake don't do
Caption: that
Caption: and I realized I'd made a really big
Caption: mistake I got in a bit of a Twitter
Caption: conversation with someone about safaris
Caption: reading mode and I forgotten about the
Caption: HTML attributes arguably the most
Caption: powerful part of HTML there's not just
Caption: elements in HTML they have a whole bunch
Caption: of attributes that you can use in order
Caption: to provide more context and information
Caption: to your page so I went through this
Caption: process of adding the right HTML
Caption: elements and then in Safari reader mode
Caption: I got a description I got my name and my
Caption: byline at the top of the article and I
Caption: was like yes this works HTML it's not a
Caption: lie it's fantastic I don't have to
Caption: cancel my presentation huzzah
Caption: now before I tell you how I did that I'm
Caption: gonna mention search because it is
Caption: related but we will get back to it now
Caption: search they rely on like crawlers and
Caption: BOTS that index your website's content
Caption: and then it uses an algorithm to
Caption: determine the relevance of the content
Caption: to our search keywords now search engine
Caption: crawlers behave a lot like screen
Caption: readers they can't at least
Caption: now intelligently understand audio-video
Caption: and imagery so they rely on text
Caption: alternatives and well-written content to
Caption: kind of understand what the value of
Caption: your pages and if you look at a Google
Caption: result what it does is it takes the
Caption: title element from your page and then it
Caption: takes the h1 and then h2 to provide an
Caption: idea of what the content on the page is
Caption: but when the pages HTML structure isn't
Caption: clear it can have a really negative
Caption: impact on this also it can impact where
Caption: your search result appears on which page
Caption: in Google because it's much harder for
Caption: the search engines to identify the type
Caption: of content that you might find on the
Caption: page and the more information and
Caption: context that you give these spots and
Caption: the crawlers the better they can match
Caption: your content to relevant keywords so
Caption: keeping in mind the reading apps and
Caption: search engines and how search engines
Caption: rely on more context and information to
Caption: match the keywords this brings me to
Caption: micro data now microdata is used to nest
Caption: metadata on existing content in web
Caption: pages search engines web crawlers apps
Caption: assistive tech they all process metadata
Caption: from a web page and use it to provide a
Caption: richer browsing experience for users and
Caption: in order to use it we can make use of
Caption: something called schema.org now
Caption: schema.org is a collection of
Caption: vocabularies about various types of
Caption: content and there are a bunch of them
Caption: online this one's probably the most
Caption: popular and it is used by the major
Caption: search engines and this allows other
Caption: technologies to understand what our
Caption: content is and there are all types of
Caption: vocabularies like person article
Caption: creative work publisher so on there
Caption: hates the websites pretty ugly but it's
Caption: worth checking out now in order to use
Caption: it we can use HTML attributes
Caption: specifically itemscope itemtype and atom
Caption: problem
Caption: so I'm going to show you how I got my
Caption: name at the top of the reading apps by
Caption: defining person as metadata on my page
Caption: now the way that I did this was I have a
Caption: paragraph and inside that I have by
Caption: Mandy Michael and on the paragraph I add
Caption: the item scope and what this does is it
Caption: creates a new item and it says anything
Caption: inside that paragraph is considered part
Caption: of the scope of my item then I add the
Caption: item type and I choose a vocabulary from
Caption: schema.org in this case I went with
Caption: person and what this does is it says
Caption: this items context is about a person and
Caption: it looks at the schema.org person's
Caption: structure and it's like Google that's a
Caption: person I know what to do with that now
Caption: the last step is defining a child of
Caption: that item so in this case I wanted to
Caption: make myself up as the author so I
Caption: wrapped my name in a span and I added
Caption: the attribute of item prop and the value
Caption: of that is author which is part of the
Caption: person schema there are all sorts of
Caption: things that you can do age gender if you
Caption: want to what you're good at
Caption: CSS padding dogs buying really amazing
Caption: pets you know you can put all sorts of
Caption: information around what a person does
Caption: who they are and this helps to provide
Caption: more content so if you searched from
Caption: Andy Michael it would probably come up
Caption: with by our dogs why dogs a good article
Caption: and this is really important because we
Caption: have to remember that sometimes he HTML
Caption: elements are not enough we need to
Caption: provide additional context and
Caption: information using metadata and other
Caption: attributes because technology can't tell
Caption: the difference between a paragraph with
Caption: my name in it and a paragraph with some
Caption: other random text from the page so we
Caption: need to make our content more explicit
Caption: and there are all sorts of HTML
Caption: attributes that we can do use in order
Caption: to do this
Caption: so Aria attributes are another really
Caption: good one that's used by assistive tech
Caption: you can use that to mark up the content
Caption: on your page to be more well understood
Caption: and provide more context for screen
Caption: readers so you can use Aria label on
Caption: your navigation element to say this is
Caption: Manor or this is foot enough or related
Caption: links you can add a role of search on
Caption: your inputs so that they know that it's
Caption: such you can add a type of email on an
Caption: input and say hey I expect an email in
Caption: this this is all really useful and
Caption: valuable context and information that we
Caption: can provide the browser and other
Caption: technologies with how to use our page
Caption: now I've only really shown a very small
Caption: tiny example of different technology
Caption: that tries to use our websites and how
Caption: they try to consume and interpret and
Caption: display our content and the impact that
Caption: HTML plays in making that work now there
Caption: are a lot of other browsers and aside
Caption: from Chrome and Firefox there are a lot
Caption: of search engines there are a lot of
Caption: apps and they all are going to rely on
Caption: that semantic HTML yesterday I was in in
Caption: Melbourne at code and Jason O'Neil he's
Caption: from Perth he did an amazing
Caption: presentation on speech synthesis and how
Caption: important HTML was in order for
Caption: technology to synthesize and use and
Caption: read and interpret content on our pages
Caption: using speech and I forget what the other
Caption: one is called really really important
Caption: and sound is only going to become more
Caption: valuable as people start trying to
Caption: navigate their website by voice commands
Caption: like hey click on that or jump to that
Caption: heading if you don't use semantic hTML
Caption: you're not going to be able to do that
Caption: and you're gonna have to do all that
Caption: work again instead of just doing it from
Caption: the start so what I'm hoping is that
Caption: when you start writing your website so
Caption: you'll
Caption: or even your tutorials and demos that
Caption: you choose the right HTML element and
Caption: attributes to best represent your
Caption: content because whilst a lot of us
Caption: probably have a good understanding of
Caption: HTML there's new people starting every
Caption: day in tact that don't know that and
Caption: it's our responsibility to make sure
Caption: that they understand HTML value and that
Caption: they use it properly otherwise we're
Caption: letting them down and we're letting down
Caption: anybody who tries to use our websites
Caption: with not well written HTML
Caption: and it's important to understand that
Caption: hTML is not just the foundation that we
Caption: build our websites on it's vital in
Caption: making sure that our websites are
Caption: functional across different platforms
Caption: and technologies and that they work as
Caption: we expected them to because if you use
Caption: HTML to its fullest from the beginning
Caption: you're not just saving yourself a heap
Caption: of time by making the most out of its
Caption: built-in features you're making it more
Caption: functional for people and for BOTS and
Caption: for technology not just for now but
Caption: whatever comes in the future and
Caption: yesterday when I was at code
Caption: I said HTML is kind of like that friend
Caption: that was really really good to you and
Caption: did heaps for you and then one day they
Caption: were like you don't care about me you
Caption: don't appreciate me and they leave and
Caption: then you're like oh you did so much
Caption: for me and you miss them because they're
Caption: not there anymore so I think we need to
Caption: make sure that we value HTML as much as
Caption: we do everything else because if it
Caption: wasn't here we would really feel the
Caption: pain so that's all what I did want to
Caption: mention Julie Grundy she's from Perth
Caption: she helped me with the accessibility
Caption: stuff
Caption: Riki mondello rescued me from my
Caption: existential crisis on html's importance
Caption: in safaris reader mode and also of
Caption: course burn toys creative for their
Caption: totally amazing
Caption: illustrations thank you
Caption: [Applause]